zone europe bonjour et bienvenue dans un
europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen de
strasbourg est réalisée en association
avec paix et 78 voici le sommaire de ce
nouveau numéro numéro spécial
franco-allemand dans quelques instants
je recevrai hans-dieter loupias
ambassadeur d'allemagne en france dans
notre rubrique culture nous vous
parlerons de la chute réalisé par oliver
hirschbiegel un film qui raconte les
derniers jours d'hitler en 45 dans son
bunker la chancellerie voyager dans
l'assiette l'allemand martin 6 mo de
cache l2 cuisines de l'hôtel molitor à
paris nous dévoilera sa recette des amis
motards mais avant que représente
l'amitié franco-allemande pour les
eurodéputés écoutez les allemands
andreas fable l'ars patrick berg et de
la française si l'héroïne soon europe à
représente le fondement même de cette
europe aid et de nos institutions
européennes qui sont nés après conflits
mondiaux qu'on reconnaît qu'on a connu
et donc c'est cette amitié
franco-allemande c'est tout le symbole
de notre europe et de la paix qu'on a
voulu en construisant cette europe a
fait savoir à tous my shoe kenteris
premièrement nos deux nations nos deux
pays
ce tome sont unis par des liens très
forts tu fristch et qui remonte sa des
raisons historiques spécialement surtout
avec la première guerre mondiale et la
seconde guerre mondiale et je pense que
les deux nations ont très bien réussi
dans le passé
dans la décennie après la seconde guerre
mondiale à s'unifier et à trouver un
terrain commun dans les domaines les
plus politiques alors l'amitié franco
allemande est la plus belle chose de
l'europe car les allemands s'intéressent
à la france et les français
s'intéressent à l'allemagne et de plus
beau c'est dans ma circonscription qui a
maintenant plus de ponts que jamais
qu'ils joignent à la france l allemagne
et j'espère qu'il y aura encore de plus
de ponts mais d'une part il ya les les
trucs en construction mais plus
important c'est les relations humaines
et c'est important que tous les écoles
font des échanges scolaires
donc je pense que c'est très important
actuellement les allemands et français
l'amitié franco allemande est très
importante pour l'union européenne et
pour l'europe
en ce qui concerne les politiques de
sécurité et les politiques de défense
les politiques agricoles c'est très
important de réunir ses forces entre
deux pays pete wentz 13 zone europe /
sensations
bonjour je reçois aujourd'hui son
excellence en dieter lukasz ambassadeur
d'allemagne en france
bonjour bonjour alors merci nous de nous
accueillir ici chez vous à l'ambassade
d'allemagne à paris
alors on en parlait tout à l'heure aof
le 22 janvier dernier c'était la journée
franco allemande alors l'occasion de
célébrer une amitié une coopération
entre nos deux pays
pour vous qui est allemand qu'est ce que
représente cette journée est ce que
c'est important de célébrer l'amitié
absolument je pense qu'il s'agit là
d'une amitié franco-allemande du
partenariat unique en europe qui joue un
rôle majeur pour l'intégration
européenne et la réconciliation
franco-allemande est important dans
cette espèce qui est en porte vraiment
c'est bâtir à un avenir ensemble et ça
ou un avis c'est vraiment leur
responsabilité de l'amitié
franco-allemande vraiment de t'être au
service d'une europe unie hull faire en
sorte que cette europe soit soit plus
forte soit plus souveraine alors est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya encore beaucoup
d'efforts à faire de chaque côté pour
renforcer cette amitié ou est-ce que par
les générations qui se succèdent et les
souvenirs de la guerre et les rancoeurs
à ce que tout ça se dissipe au sein des
peuples ou est ce que c'est encore
quelque chose qui ait marqué à mon avis
là c'est un métier franck au monde des
vins doit encore plus importante parce
que nous faisons face aux défis énormes
donc l'émergence des deux grandes
puissances comme la chine des pandémies
comme comme lakovic le changement
climatique
tout ça ce sont des défis qui sont
énormes et auxquels nous faisons face
seulement si nous travaillons ensemble
en franco allemand justement il faut
qu'on travaille ensemble on dit souvent
que le couple franco-allemand on amène à
un couple c'est plus seulement une
amitié c'est presque de l'amour entre la
france et l'allemagne ont dit que ces
moteurs c'est le moteur de l'europe
est-ce que vous partager ce sentiment et
pourquoi on peut parler de moteur au
sein de l'union européenne on peut
parler d'un moteur au sein de l'union
européenne parce que la france et
l'allemagne souvent donne une impulsion
en union européenne en ce qui concerne
des questions très très très importante
je cite aussi l'exemple du plan de
relance qu'on a adopté l'année dernière
pour faire face à la crise pandémique
donc on a pris cette décision au sein de
l'union européenne
mais c'était à l'itie initiative prise
par la chancelière mais clé de président
me coran macron donc c'est un set un bon
exemple n'est ce pas s'agit de 750
milliards 750 milliards d'euros cette
zone est une réponse à une réponse
exceptionnelle à la crise exceptionnelle
et si tu as vraiment aussi à une
initiative franco allemande alors dans
un couple il ya de l'entente mais
également de la discorde souvent comment
ça se passe quand la france et
l'allemagne sont pas d'accord en europe
ça se passe assez souvent que nos points
de départ sont différents ce qui est
normal parce que ce sont des pays avec
des des cultures différentes
parfois aussi des intérêts différents
mais enfin nous sommes tous conscients
du fait que seulement ensemble on peut
faire en france et l'europe c'est à dire
les points de départ sont différents
mais enfin il ya toujours l'effort
d'arriver à un compromis et à l'action
commune
justement le début de cette amitié de ce
couple franco-allemand on se souvient
par exemple de françois mitterrand et
helmut kohl qui qui se serrent la main à
verdun
mais avant il y avait déjà de gaulle et
adenauer qui ont commencé et qui ont
bâti les premières pierres de ce couple
comment est-ce que ça a débuté comment
est ce qu'on s'est dit finalement
marchons sur le même chemin et allons
dans la même direction mais c'était
l'initiative du général de gaulle et d
mes chances eliane nabaa quelques
instants après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'était pendant une visite en allemagne
en 60 que de que le général de gaulle à
a pris l'initiative pour un traité
franco-allemand qui a été conclu en 63
c'était le traité de l'élysée qui a
vraiment posé les jalons pour la
réconciliation franco-allemande et aussi
pour ce partenariat franco-allemand
énigme alors la france et l'allemagne
font partie de l'union européenne
l'union européenne est régie par
l'espace schengen qui permet la libre
circulation au sein des pays de l'union
européenne mais lors de la crise
sanitaire de kobe de 10,9 dont on parle
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant il ya
eu des tensions entre la france et
l'allemagne on l'a vu notamment avec les
travailleurs transfrontaliers en moselle
notamment qui était obligé pour aller en
allemagne de se faire tester très
régulièrement ou et pas forcément dans
l'autre sens la france n'a pas forcément
mis ces mesures à exécution pourquoi est
ce que dans le traitement de cette crise
la france et l'allemagne n'ont pas été
un couple comme on peut l'entendre dans
la gestion de l'union européenne au
début de la crise l'année hier c'était
une phase on peu difficile parce qu'il y
avait là donc des réflexes you know mais
me semble qu'on a tiré de l'ue sont donc
de cette situation donc aujourd'hui donc
il n'y a absolument pas de fermetures de
frontières il n'y a aussi pas de
contrôles à la frontière et s'il y a des
questions à discuter on fait ça ensemble
on a créé donc d
des institutions des comités dans lequel
en traite c'est question ensemble pour
arriver à une solution commune
justement pour traiter ça ensemble il y
a deux ans il me semble en 2019
l'assemblée parlementaire franco
allemande a été créé c'est une première
pourquoi est ce que c'est important que
la france et l'allemagne se réunissent
tout d'abord entre elle et sous forme
d'assemblées mai puis c'est une
assemblée franco-allemande parlementaire
a été créée par le traité
d'aix-la-chapelle et jeu pour la
première fois nous disposons maintenant
d'une assemblée qui réunit les
parlementaires français et allemand
jusqu'au traité des chapelles
d'aix-la-chapelle il y avait une
coopération très étroite entre les
gouvernements maintenant il ya aussi une
coopération renforcée entre ce qui
représente le peuple et ça c'est très
important et je trouve c'est une
expérience très encourageante parce
qu'elle est parlementaires discutent des
questions très concrètes par exemple
comme 2
donc le trafic transfrontalier les
liaisons ferroviaires la conférence
coopération en matière de défense par
exemple
donc à mon avis c'est très utile et très
important et justement est-ce que vous
pensez que les peuples français et
allemands sont contents de ça est ce que
les autres pays européens ne voient pas
ça contre un affront peut-être à l'union
européenne parce que finalement la
france l allemagne se réunissent dans
leur coin avant d'aller voir les autres
pays c'est une coopération au service de
l'europe
si si nous menons ce travail en commun
au service de l'europe il y aura pas de
problème c'est quelque chose
les autres et abu attend membres et en
attendent aussi de la france et de
l'allemagne qui font des propositions
pour l'union européenne pour notre
travail commun en europe
merci beaucoup aux visiteurs lukasz
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes ambassadeur d'allemagne en
france encore merci pour cet entretien
merci à vous du cinéma à présent avec la
chute réalisé par oliver hirschbiegel ce
film est sorti en 2004 raconte les
derniers jours de hitler en 45 dans son
bunker de la chancellerie
thomas fleisher nous en dit plus sur
l'europe
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
film allemand intitulé la chute des
routeurs gang en vo
sorti en 2004 réalisé par oliver
hirschbiegel le film relate les derniers
jours de hitler en 45 dans le bunker de
la chancellerie lors de la prise de
berlin par l'armée russe
on conseille à hitler de sur berlin mais
ces derniers refusent jusqu'à son
suicide ce seront donc des accès de rage
envers ses généraux des décisions
absurdes un mépris pour la population
civile qui mérite de lui selon lui sa
faim sa chute donc ne reste côtés
d'hitler que ses généraux son entourage
personnel donc goebbels et eva braun et
les secrétaires d'hitler qui veulent
rester auprès de lui à propos des
secrétaires il y en a une qui joue un
rôle important dans le film à savoir
travaux de young qui est la plus jeune
des quatre secrétaires du führer elle
témoigne début à la fin du film elle
était embauchée en 43 et c'est
d'ailleurs elle qui tu es qui tapera son
testament
elle s'enfuira du gong heures après le
suicide d'hitler tous apposé l'intérêt
du film contrairement à d'autres films
sur hitler sait déjà qu'il est tourné en
allemand ce qui donne une vraie
crédibilité aux scènes où hitler
incarnée par bruno ganz part dans ces
crises d'hystérie en fait bruno ganz a
pu s'inspirer d'un enregistrement unique
de sept minutes où hitler en privé
félicitait le fait lemarchal mannheim en
42 hitler ayant toujours refusé le
moindre enregistrement hors de ses
apparitions publiques
gans a également étudié la maladie de
parkinson dont hitler souffrait il a
également étudié la façon particulière
de parler d'hitler avec son accent
autrichien auprès d'un jeune acteur
originaire de la région de bras know i'm
in ville natale d'hitler au côté de
grandes sont à alexandra maria lara qui
joue la secrétaire à une offerte qui
interprète albert je perds ou encore
thomas kretschmann michael mendl avec
cette particularité que beaucoup de
comédiens comédiennes ressemble même
s'il ya bien sûr le maquillage aux vrais
personnages qu'ils incarnent
pour l'anecdote si on voit plusieurs
or violente dans ce film on ne voit pas
celle d'hitler et d'eva braun puisque le
parti pris du film et de se baser sur
des témoignages de personnes présentes
dans le bunker
or personne n'a assisté à la mort
d'hitler et de sa femme une grande
partie des extérieurs a été tourné à
saint pétersbourg la scène la plus
difficile à tourner pour l'équipe et les
comédiens a été celle où magda goebbels
empoisonne ses enfants en parlant de
poison justement comme la majorité des
capsules étaient fabriqués dans les
camps les allemands qui se sont suicidés
à cette époque non seulement à vallet le
poison mais utilise à une arme pour être
bien sûr de réussir leur coup c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle hitler en
poison empoisonnera sa chienne avant
afin d'être certain que le poison serait
efficace sur lui plus légèrement
les scènes de rage du führer ont donné
lieu à des détournements sur le net ou
des parodies évoque là qu'il la colère
d'hitler à propos de la décevante bande
annonce d'avatar ou du retour du retard
de la sortie de harry potter et le
prince de sang mêlé les mimosas
vous connaissez sans doute une recette
revisité par l'allemand martin 6 mo de
cache chef de cuisine de l'hôtel molitor
à paris regardez saône europe voyage
bonjour je m'appelle martin simard cage
chef de cuisine au thème molitor donc
aujourd'hui je vous présentais notre f
mimosas donc neuf mozart c'est un
produit phare quand propos sur la carte
la carte diverses la brasserie donc on
revisite en fait le plat on revisite le
plat de huf une mosaïque un peu de
modernité donc un petit suisse de
modernité donc sur l'avenue mozart où il
ya les oeufs bio la truffe trouve d'été
aux truffes de bourgogne donc trip de
truffe d'été c'est maintenant truffe de
bourgogne c'est c'est c en hiver
ensuite vous avez la création nette du
cresson mayonnaise et truffe hachée donc
polissoir aujourd'hui l'oeuf en fait
aujourd'hui je voulais mettre ses neuf à
la carte
parce que je voulais rendre l'oeuf un
peu plus sexy de plus élégant
et en fait je cherchais ce produit j'ai
cherché qu'est ce que je pourrais faire
egloff parce qu'aujourd'hui les eaux
partait en voit partout je voulais faire
un oeuf classique mais comme avec un peu
un petit fils de modernité du coup je
cherchais eu deux fils mozart dont gloss
mimosas s'est un peu classique et j'ai
cherché avec un produit qui pourrait
marcher avec
donc là je prie la créa sonnette et le
cresson en fait il va ramener un peu de
fraîcheur à un autre l'a donc là je vais
commencer par les eaux donc les oeufs
bio je vais les cuirs jeu clients deux
façons donc je vais des cuirs neuf
minutes pendant neuf qu'il est un peu
plus mollo et j'ai le cuir
une deuxième partie 12 minutes pour que
ce soit un peu plus que lui donc
aujourd'hui pourquoi neuf minutes pour
que ça reste bien mieux et qu'on n'a pas
neuf qu'il est toujours
je sais qu'on allait à my own et c'est
tout mais il faut que ça soit comme à
ces fonds dont et après l'autre l'aude
l'oeuf ces faits pouvant me moser
donc moi mimosas je fais avec la petite
trappe et il faut que ça soit un peu
plus dur que ça fasse quand même un film
au hasard
[Musique]
donc là je reçois les yeux je l'aimé à
refroidir pendant cinq minutes pour
qu'il soit bien frais
donc là les 800 il s'enfuit et cahiers
et là je vais les mettre à égoutter
un petit peu comme ça moi je l'aimé
toujours dans un peu d'eau comme ça il
ya tout les cookies qui tombe au fond au
fond de la park est tombé ensuite je
vais rappeler mes yeux pour faire le fus
mozart
donc là je vais commencer à plancher de
création tant qu'il ya 2/3 cuite et un
tiers cru pour qu'un cru parce qu'il
faut que ça ramène un peu de fraîcheur
et quand c'est cuit souvent la fraîcheur
en fait il s'en va la halle au bouillon
vous laissez cuire pendant 5 à 10
minutes
donc ça dépend il faut que ça soit que
du corps
donc j'ai rajouté un peu de sel pour
fixer le chlorophylle et pour amener du
goût et après j'ai mixé avec un peu
d'huile d'olive
donc je vais monter aux huiles d'olive
et je verrai assaisonner avec un peu de
poids un peu de sel donc là on va se
donner notre funosas donc très classique
une mayonnaise fait maison donc et que
bien moutarde et avec un peu de vinaigre
de xérès
j'ajoute de 3 cuir
ensuite j'ai rajouté la truffe
edsel
fabre
ciboulette
un peu de vinaigre
donc là je mélange tout pour que ça soit
homogène
l'appareil battre haut de maillot dedans
mais assez pour que ce soit pas trop
compacte donc là vous voyez la
consistance il est quand même assez
l'équipe quoi donc là pour adresser ses
plus simple en poche à douille donc les
poche à douille
c'est souvent pour la batterie mais nous
on cuisine on utilise comme assez
souvent
va pour gagner du temps
donc là les créations pour tester la
cuisson vous écraser une fois entre
denain donc ça s'écrase quand même assez
facilement donc si vous voulez regarder
dans la glace et bien que lui
tant que jean lfg refroidit pas donc
gmx à chaud avec manquera son cru par
une belle consistance
donc là les créations il est cuit donc
elle est bien cuit j'aime être dans le
mixeur
vous pourrez rajouter un petit peu de
buts qu'ils sont très peu comme ça
ensuite un peu de crachin cru que je
mets dedans pour robin hobb c'est un
petit peu plat que le coulis si on lui
couler trop les toofan et après je
mentais à vis des olives ans
voilà c'est bon
donc n'hésitez pas de bien mélanger
bien mélanger et ajouter un peu de jus
de cuisson à chaque fois donc
[Applaudissements]
donc là tout est cuit tout mxr donc là
vous avez une consistance qu'il est bien
lié voilà
donc là ce qui est important c'est le
bien refroidir sur glace donc je rajoute
toujours un peu de glace avec un peu
d'eau comme ça ça refroidit rapidement
et on va fixer la chlorophylle comme ça
vous avez quand même à un coulis qu'il
est bien dire quoi bien lisse et bien
vers l'allée but c'est vraiment d'avoir
quelque chose qui ressort heureux qui
fait penser en fait aux créations dans
l'assiette
donc là j'ai acheté un peu de poids un
petit moulin pas pas trop qu'on ressent
bien le création est un peu de sel
assez bon donc l'âge et des bas c'est
moins classe ont donc le cresson en fait
c'est le coup les créations c'est
vraiment là pour c'est comme un petit
condiments qui va repasser le plat quoi
donc là je vais commencer à tailler les
yeux
tout ça
donc là comme vous voyez en fait c'est
un oeuf qu'il est un petit peu mollet
mais qu aux mains en tant que le but
c'est vraiment d'avoir la gourmandise
est pas quelque chose qu'il est trop
c'est quoi donc je taille les ltte les
deux petites un bout ça c'est pour poser
les yeux après
donc là je vais assaisonner les yeux
fleur de sel partout
[Musique]
pas donc c'est super important les bien
assaisonner les yeux parce que sinon
après ses fans un oeuf mimosa fade c'est
pas bon
je vais rajouter mois mimosas assez
généreux
donc là on va commencer sur l'agglo
dressage et
le dressage va commencer eq 3e donc là
j'ai fait un buzz pour goûter pour faire
goûter
donc c'est super important en cuisinant
goût toujours hop ça j'ai rajouté mans
le coulis de cresson sur le sur les pas
ramener un peu de peps
je rajoute quelques points de cresson
sur l'assiette
s'engager ajoute la truffe là on est
plutôt sur la trouve des terres donc
trouve des télécoms a c'est assez léger
c'est un trouve qu'il est calé plonge
dedans
donc il n'est pas lé pa lé pas comme la
truffe noire
donc c'est pour ça en goule est beaucoup
moins puissant et ensuite je rajoute la
cressonnette tant que la cré sonnette
c'est là c'est un peu la même famille
comme le cra sont donc le classement
c'est en grand format et cressonnette
c'est sa poussée un petit format a
concédé petit germes
que je rajoute sur chaque oeuf
la petite cressonnette c'est pour
repérer c'est encore un peu le loeuff
comme le fait un petit peu lourd avec la
mayonnaise
c'est pour alléger en fait le tout la
pâte ou le plat quoi la pollen etc
d'autre en fait le loft mimosas c'est un
des premiers plats que je crée en fait
pour le
pour le moniteur du bio en arriver donc
on a mis à la brasserie à la en place
l'année passée
donc nos duff mimosas classique avec du
cresson honnête avec un peu de peps
l'oeuf qui n'est pas trop dur donc bien
moleux la truffe pas ramené le goût de
champion la petite cressonnette faut
pour au peuple c'est le plat là la
petite anecdote passé mon premier plat
du molitor ce numéro spécial
franco-allemand de zone europe est
terminé merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site
internet et notre application radio
sensations et également sur tv 78 à très
bientôt
bonne soirée sonne robe sûr sensation